ايران تختلق داخليا وخارجيا تظاهرات
الحراك ضد النظام لا تهدا بينما العزله
تحكم بمفاصل النظام الايراني لقلعه المميد
للتظاهرات التي فجرها غضبا مقتل مهس اميلي
المحتاجين هتافا ضد المرشد تهاجم الشرطه
المتظاهرين وتعتقل منهم المئات السلطات
وجهه الاتهام بقضايا ملفقه يصل بعضها لحكم
الاعدام لنحو 800 متظاهير والجريمه
الاحتجاج ضد النظام
النظام الذي لا يفقه يهاجمه الاخر الدول
الغربيه لاعلان تضامنها ووقوفها الى جانب
المحتجين
الالماني
لقمعها الاحتياجات الى تجديد الرئيس
الفرنسي ووصف ما يحدث في ايران للمره
الثانيه بانها ثوره مواصلا تاكيده ان
العقوبات المفروضه على النظام يجب ان لا
يتاثر بها الشعب الايراني فيما يواصل
الاتحاد الاوروبي فرض عقوبات اضافيه ضد
المسؤولين قمع الاحتجاجات حيث تشمل الحزمه
الجديده واح 31 تصنيفا لانتهاكات حقوق
الانسان تستهدف الافراد والكيانات بفرض
حظر على الاصول وتجميد السفر
مد التظاهرات مستمره وبتكتيكات مختلفه
وواسطه تضامن الدولي غير مسبوق في ما يجد
النظام الايراني نفسه في مازق مواجهه
الداخليه واخرى خارجيه